- When the doctors diagnosed
me, they told me that
I wouldn't be able to clothe
myself or feed myself,
that I would need
assistance for pretty much
everything I did.
My body is more than just a sack.
It's actually an instrument
to do great things with,
and I've been a professional
dancer for six years.
(captivating flute music)
I'm Jerron Herman, and I have
hemiplegia cerebral palsy.
Cerebral palsy is a neuromuscular
disorder that affects
messages going to the
muscles in your body.
So the result is involuntary
motion and spasticity.
Hemiplegia refers to me
because it affects only
the left side of my body.
- [Instructor] Alright,
let me see you, please.
- Heidi Latsky dance is
a company that integrates
people with disabilities.
- Ready, and one.
(music plays)
- I've always been an
advocate for those to pursue
the antithesis of the thing
that is their limitation.
Why dance?
Primarily because of the
physical diagnosis I was given.
My body is the instrument,
and if I'm a disabled person
and my body's the instrument,
it's pretty audacious.
(intense cello music)
As I've been told, my arabesque is crazy,
but it's from my left side,
and it comes from my left leg
shooting up to the air.
And my balance is based
on my right side being
the main impetus for my
control, so that these things
that were perceived as negatives are now
folded into the choreography.
When I am in the moment, and I'm dancing,
I feel this calm that I've got this.
Everything is working
together, and then some.
Dance has relieved me of a
stereotype that is placed
on people with disabilities.